the opening scene is set in a mental
institution where a teenage girl named
Sumi is undergoing treatment for shock
and psychosis the doctor tries to talk
to her by showing her family photographs
but the traumatized girl remains silent
the doctor that inquires about her
experiences leading to her
hospitalization but she gives no
response the scene then cuts to a few
days later when Sumi returns to her
family's isolated Countryside residence
with her father muhyun and her younger
sister Su Yan upon their arrival both
sisters hesitate to enter as they hate
their stepmother Yoon Zhu as a result
they head down to appear by the lake and
enjoy some fresh air a short while later
they are summoned back to the house
where they are greeted by yunju's
feigned welcome though she pretends to
be pleasant the Two Sisters remain
unresponsive and walk upstairs to their
room inside her room Sumi starts
unpacking and arranging her belongings
only to discover that there is already
an exact same diary on her desk she is
further surprised to find clothes with
the same design in her appearing as if
she isn't allowed to wear other
patterned clothes later on the family
gathers for dinner but the atmosphere
remains quiet eunju eventually breaks
the Silence by announcing that she has
invited her brother and his wife to
dinner the next day however nobody
appears interested in this and even the
father hastily finishes his meal to
leave Sumi then expresses her
disapproval of dining with her
Stepmother's brother with this she
leaves the dining table followed by her
sister as they make their way to their
room sue me who is protective of her
younger sister asks her to confide in
her if their stepmother ever bothers her
following this everyone retires to their
respective beds muhyun seems
uncomfortable sharing a bed with you and
jio so he goes to sleep on the living
room sofa Instead This highlights the
strange relationship between the two of
them at the stroke of midnight Su Yan is
awakened by a strange noise coming from
outside her room soon after the door
creaks open revealing a woman's hand
slowly extending inward overwhelmed by
fear see Eon swiftly hides herself under
the blanket but the blanket gradually
tugs away as well moments later the door
suddenly slams shut freaking the girl
out as a result of this she runs to
sumi's room and confides in her hearing
the incident Sumi walks downstairs to
check but only sees the television
broadcasting static she also finds her
father asleep on the sofa and takes a
moment to adjust his blanket just then
her stepmother shows up from the Shadows
telling her not to disturb him however
Sumi starts in arguments and abruptly
leaves she then consoles her sister with
a comforting hug and the two fall asleep
during the early hours of mourning Sumi
is plagued by a nightmarish Vision
involving her dead mother upon Awakening
she is confronted by a horrifying
Apparition a long-haired woman who
crawls along the ground the spectral
figure becomes aware of sumi's gaze so
she stands to face her with Sumi Frozen
in fear the woman starts to approach her
the ghostly figure hovers with blood
trickling from her leg and a hand
abruptly emerges from beneath her dress
just then sue me snaps out of it and
realizes that everything was just a
dream shortly after she notices blood
stains on her bedding as well as on her
sister's shorts indicating that they are
on their periods in order to get the
sanitary pads Sumi heads to her
Stepmother's room where she discovers
that Yoon Zhu is also menstruating it is
a bit strange that the three women in
the house have synchronized their
menstrual cycles on this
day is it though afterwards the two
sisters are on the balcony whistling
their biological mother's favorite
melody in the midst of this they are
approached by their father who tells
them not to stay outside as it's cold
Sumi broaches the topic of getting rid
of suyon's wardrobe but her father
reminds her that they have agreed not to
talk about that the relationship between
father and daughter appears to be cold
marked by frequent disagreements later
in the day Sumi finds some family
photographs which reveal that yunju is
formerly an in-home nurse who had cared
for their terminally ill mother prior to
her passing just then sue young enters
the room and the two sisters rummaged
through their mother's belongings
together amidst this Sumi discovers
bruises on suyon's arm she angrily asks
if their stepmother did this but the
young girl refuses to answer and runs
out determined to seek answers Sumi
questions yunju about the injuries but
her stepmom adamantly refuses to
apologize for her actions the same night
yunju's brother soon Kyu along with his
wife mih arrived for dinner during their
meal yunju cracked some insensitive
jokes creating an odd situation for
everyone not long after me he abruptly
collapses to the ground and begins
convulsing soon q and muhyun rushed to
her Aid and eventually managed to calm
her down and once she recovers the
couple drives away on Route me he
confides in her husband revealing that
she saw the ghost of a dead girl beneath
the kitchen sink during her seizure back
at home yunju notices the sink door
opening on its own curious she slowly
approaches and closes it she then
proceeds to inspect beneath the sick but
finds nothing amiss unbeknownst to her a
girl with long hair is seated at the
dining table sensing an eerie presence
yunju turns around but the girl vanishes
just then she spots a hair clip on the
floor confused she bends to pick it up
but a ghostly hand suddenly grasps her
arm scaring her heart out she hastily
Retreats but soon finds herself face to
face with the girl from the dining table
she later confides in her husband
explaining that strange occurrences have
been happening in the house ever since
sumi's return however muhyun does not
believe in her and asks her to take a
rest for a while later on muhyun makes a
grim Discovery yunju's beloved pet bird
has been killed inside its cage upon
learning of this yunju storms into
suyon's room in a fit of anger there she
finds that her pictures have been torn
apart with her face deliberately
scratched out convinced that these
actions are done by the girls she
physically assaults suyon and locks her
in the closet not long after Sumi hears
her sister screams and rushes to check
on her hearing suyon's Cries From the
closet she hastily unlocks it and
releases her Sumi then apologizes for
not being able to hear her cry sooner
and vows to protect her from further
harm a short while later their father
walks in and asks Sumi about the reason
why she's acting weirdly ever since she
returned Sumi tells him about yunju's
mistreatment towards suion in an
unexpected turn of events her father
begs her to stop acting out and informs
her that Su yon is dead however Sumi
refuses to accept this as she sees her
sister right next to her sobbing
uncontrollably the following morning
yoonju drags a blood-stained sack
through the house and starts beating it
with a stick the noise awakens sue me he
then heads downstairs to investigate
upon witnessing a trail of blood
staining the floor she believes that her
sister is inside the sack she tries to
open it but struggles in her efforts
soon after her stepmother appears from
behind and is ready to throw boiling
water on her this incites a violent
altercation between the two during which
Sumi hits her head on the counter and
Falls unconscious following this yunju
drags her into the living room before
retrieving a garden statue as Sumi
regains Consciousness she finds her
stepmother kneeling beside her yunju
claims that Sumi will never be able to
get rid of all the painful memories from
the past because will follow her like a
ghost she then raises the heavy garden
statue with an intention to smash it
into sumi's head but fortunately muhyun
arrives in the neck of time prompting
her to retreat he notices Sumi lying
down injured on the floor and quickly
carries her to the bedroom he then
starts looking around the house for some
first aid amidst this he notices the
messy state of his house causing him to
feel strange he also sees some bloodied
doll tied up in the sack in the closet
shortly after muhyun finds his wife
sitting on the living room couch he
gives her some medication while also
asking her to control her violent
Behavior after a brief conversation
muhyun exits the room seconds later the
room's door opens again and a person
wearing a suit enters the camera pans to
reveal that this person is none other
than yunju while the one previously
Seated on the couch is Sue me it is
ultimately revealed that Sue me and her
father were alone in the house the
entire
scene moves to a flashback and we are
shown that Sue me was the one dragging
the sack across the floor earlier the
content in the sack was actually a
porcelain doll and she was the one who
killed the pet bird it is further
disclosed that she returned home without
her sister because Soo-hyun died a long
time ago finally we come to learn that
Sumi had suffered from disassociative
identity disorder in which she possessed
two distinct personalities herself and
her perception of her stepmother for
some reason she hates her stepmother a
lot as a result the conversations and
events she previously had with Soo yon
and her stepmother were the result of
her schizophrenic mind but what about
the part with yunju's sister having a
seizure on the floor that was so
confusing moreover the portrayal of the
stepmother in the earlier scene was
merely a construct of sumi's imagination
in the aftermath of this Revelation
tsumi promptly takes medication in order
to stabilize her emotions after all of
this the father and the real Union take
Sumi back to the mental institution
yunju is seen waiting outside the ward
room with a worried face after sumi's
checkup she tries to offer consolation
promising to visit her as often as
possible however Sumi remains silent
later in the evening yoonju is alone at
home when she hears footsteps coming
from suyon's old bedroom she enters the
room to investigate only to be startled
by movement behind the curtains she
proceeds to open the curtains the door
shuts from behind and the lights begin
to flicker the tension escalates as the
closet door opens on its own upon
walking closer she is confronted with a
horrifying sight a ghostly figure crawls
out and ultimately kills Yoon Jill
meanwhile in the hospital Sumi has a
smile on her face seemingly having found
peace the scene then flashes back to the
time when the children's terminally ill
mother was still alive during that
period muhyun was in an affair with
yunjil who used to serve as their
in-home nurse this betrayal devastated
thereby biological mother leading her to
commit the unthinkable inside the closet
of suyon's room the following morning
tsuyan found her mother's motionless
body setting her into a panic she tried
to revive her by shaking the lifeless
body but unfortunately this caused the
closet to collapse on top of her the
little girl struggled to escape but
couldn't lift the heavy closet hearing
the loud noise the stepmother came to
check but callously abandoned the
suffocating child instead of helping
however she had a change of heart and
began to head back halfway though she
crossed paths with Sue me who criticized
yunju for interfering with her family
enraged by sumi's words the stepmother
vented her anger on suyon by leaving her
to die she also told Sumi that she will
regret her actions one day with this
argument Sumi leaves the house in Anger
unaware of both her sister and her
mother's fate this incident traumatized
Sumi which resulted in her being placed
in the mental Hospital
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching